é muito boa noite a todos
estava a respirar fundo ainda por causa
do que ouvimos e da coragem daquela
senhora que está é e vamos mudar
rapidamente do tema porque eu hoje vim
aqui falar das cidades e da dificuldade
que é cada vez maior
nós conhecermos o significado que temos
nessa palavra parece quase um paradoxo
porque todos os dias ouvimos essa
palavra em todos os dias nos dizem é que
ela tem vários sentidos que é paulista e
mika
todos os dias nos dizem que a humanidade
está praticamente a caminho de uma taxa
altíssima da organização o brasil por
exemplo ultrapassa os 80% e nível
mundial onde iremos nos 55 mas
provavelmente a palavra urbano
organização não significa o mesmo que
cidade então era sobre isso que eu
gostava da música pode ser um caso
escolas e nunca também próprio já agora
a primeira imagem que vos trago é é
conhecida pelos geógrafos como sendo o
primeiro mapa ou primeira representação
cartográfica não lhe vamos chamar cidade
mas pelo menos tem se um ar de um de um
assentamento
ela foi descoberta no norte da d'itália
anos a ops silval canônica e orientações
várias estima se que este povoado tenha
existido acerca em quase três mil anos
bom significava que eu não sabemos num
mapa 1-0 da quem o fez não se preocupou
com isso há coisas que nos parecem
familiares por exemplo reduz a caminhos
ou vias círculos que podem indicar poços
ou pontos importantes daquelas
encantamento pontos que tanto podem ser
árvores como terrenos de cultivo muita
coisa qualquer
o que eu quero dizer é que há uma
distância um fosso enorme entre o que é
a representação e uma realidade nós não
conseguimos com sucesso
hoje quando nos dizem que qualquer coisa
na cidade é mais fácil que nos ocorre
mas nem assim esta que parece um carro
photoshop não é é é no exercício ea
idéia que ela transmite
esta ideia de densidade da comemoração
do território intensamento construído
mas também é uma ideia de cosmopolitismo
no sentido em que tudo isso nos parece
familiar todas têm impedimento do
departamento de escritórios mais
horizontais ou mais radicais nos parece
que é qualquer coisa que podia estar à
nossa porta
esta pintura dodô lorenzetti que está no
palácio local disse ana foi feita em
1937 como diz a lei e que saiba é a
primeira representação daquilo que nós
hoje podemos chamar uma paisagem tem
todos os argumentos para o cdu e se
repararem na participada da imagem
há claramente uma dicotomia estabelecida
de um lado é o campo eu rural
do outro lado esse dado é urbano as duas
estão separadas por uma muralha por uma
porta
tanto isto é a mensagem que esta que
esta imagem transmitir parece muito
clara e parece coincidir com o que nós
pensamos hoje do mesmo assunto é da
eletricidade é ao mesmo tempo um
território densamente ficado a ideia de
que cidade é qualquer coisa têm os
limites muito claros e fica dentro
desses limites quanto fora será outra
coisa qualquer
a idéia de que a cidade não é só eu
quando fomos jogar no frio só
construções mas também a sociedade e por
isso o pintor é representou uma
diversidade enorme
vamos ver em pormenor mais embaixo desde
as artes a música as letras um pregador
do baixo das arcadas um comerciante é
pessoas mais humildes que vendem
produtos agrícolas na rua um cavaleiro é
nobres a cavalo etc
a idéia de que uma cidade de alguma
forma que responderá também um grupo
social e finalmente que é esse grupo
social a será governado por alguém ou
seja ir buscar as três redes clássicas
que nós usamos em torno da palavra
cidade urbano esta representação é ao
mesmo tempo assim evita-se ou seja o
grupo social é ao mesmo tempo a pólis
donde veio polícia e política ou seja
uma forma do governo que que então será
ou irá ser muito brevemente no tempo a
cidade estado que caracterizem todo
nascimento italiana e eu ouvi isso se
refere à aquilo que é edificado e as
infra estruturas que permitem com que as
atividades que desempenham dentro do
significado funcione também é muito
vulgar é esta representação de um santo
patrono neste caso sandy menino que
segura no seu regaço como que protegendo
é própria cidade são de menino que agora
é patrimônio da humanidade muitos
conheceram com as suas torres não tem
muito que ver com defesa mas sobretudo
os sinais simbólicos de estratificação
social do poder e mais uma vez a moeda
mais uma vez esta ideia do que quase que
cidade podia ser uma taça nas nossas
mãos e nós podíamos identificar
claramente aquilo que a cidade aquilo
que não é
entretanto aconteceu lista são de menino
vindo para o século 20 é cada vez tem
menos braço para marcar
não agora excitava mas sem organização
aquilo que distingue a cidade a
organização parece ser muito claro a
organização é um processo não dizia na
prática não designar um lugar em sendo
um processo quer dizer que ela está
constantemente a tomar forma e tomar
lugar em qualquer lugar e isto é podendo
por ser um jogo de palavras não é nada
isto faz nos perceber a condição urbana
e o fenômeno urbano de uma maneira
completamente diferente isto é é como se
é nós já não tivéssemos idéia da forma
urbana do seu limite do seu centro e
organização fosse uma espécie do magma
que vai espalhando e que tem uma
intensidade cada vez mais tecnológica
desde os grandes sistemas da mobilidade
das pessoas dos automóveis das
mercadorias da informação da energia é
toda é toda a diversidade de construções
que os humanos fazem desses grandes
edifícios organizar o portos ou o portos
mar até uma simples casa e portanto
temos braços aqui
um problema de classificação que nome
dar às coisas
a cidade se tornou uma coisa com tantos
sentidos
então diz adaptado do que a realidade
como é que vamos encontrar outra
classificação capaz de nomear uma coisa
nova que é organização são conhecidas
estas estas palavras de jorge luis
borges que faz esta curiosity na
classificação de animais que ao mesmo
tempo nos parece mas depois nós vir uns
afinal nós até conseguimos concordar com
quase todas ou com todas as coisas que
estão os animais pertencentes ao
empreendedor basta que haja uma
empreendedora e outros animais com
certeza os embalsamados amestrados os
leões hoje será isto é também entram os
animais é fabulosa está como está a
seguir os cães soltos serão diferentes
dos cães presos e por aí fora e até
acabando com aqueles que de longe
parecem músicas ou seja estas formas de
classificação muito variáveis são muito
positivas na minha opinião aquelas que
nós usamos para designação o que é a
diversidade da cidade ou que é é é a
diversidade dos significados do objetivo
urbano
dizemos com um determinado o sapato tem
uma linha urbana ou que um automóvel tem
um design urbano 1941 steel vida urbano
dizemos que uma determinada sociedade é
urbana e depois quando vamos ver essas
sociedades
ela pode conter pessoas tão diferentes
como aquelas que por semana uma vez ou
duas roma tóquio nova york e uma outra
que mora debaixo de um viaduto e
perguntamos nos qual é a semelhança
entre estas duas entidades e portanto o
desafio que nós temos é procurar novas
classificações novas palavras para
designar as coisas porque senão não
teremos forma de aprender o mundo
assim fez o lineu para organizar as
espécies encontrando-a sistema de
classificação que normalmente funcionam
por muita exclusão ou é planta ou animal
e dentro de uma determinada planta ou
era uma terminada classe ou alguma outra
quase ou este sistema a priori e
produziu menos domingo
é que não só classifica os elementos
químicos através através do peso atômico
como inclusivamente vai ter muitos
quadros vazios e neste momento é o
segundo pior do que já vai em 122 real -
portanto já não é só classificaram os
que há é usar uma lógica para
inclusivamente posicionar
aqueles que não são conhecidos ou
aqueles que não ocorrendo naturalmente
são sintetizados em laboratório
não temos nada que se pareça com esta
precisão para classificarmos hoje em dia
o que é o fenômeno urbano
podemos ir lá mais simplesmente contando
uma história nova
por exemplo a idéia do ovo cozido seja
alocado bolsa revela cidade é como quem
pensa que a cidade é qualquer coisa que
tal uma gema do ovo está perfeitamente
inserida num determinado em torno da
cidade a figura é o branco é o fundo é a
oposição a cidade é o campo e isto nem
muitas e muitas imagens em muitos testes
que nós vemos hoje ainda parece ser
verdade mas nunca acreditei muito porque
há cada vez mais aos trotes ou seja esta
ideia de que a cidade cresceu muito
transformou-se no menu inspirado banda
que nunca mais acaba por facilidade
usamos muitas vezes a palavra área
metropolitana ou região metropolitana
para designar estes nomes de organização
a grande escala mas habitualmente usando
um modelo populista ou seja pensamos
sempre que há um centro dessa grande
área antropizada nessa grande área
urbana e que o resto uma preferida ou
seja este modelo contra evento a idéia
de que a cidade é uma coisa urna que é
um corpo que é um sistema mais ou menos
fechado este não é é preferia o subúrbio
terão sempre conotações negativas é
aquilo que supostamente a cidade receita
porque é muito grande porque faz fumo
faz barulho porque causa incômodos é o
seguro é o lugar onde vivem os mais
pobres entre nem mesmo isso é verdade
o social francesa já muito tempo que
inventar uma palavra seguro de dourar
para classificar é a áreas residenciais
onde mora gente que está em um nível de
vida muito alto e finalmente chegamos
aquilo que é mais que está mais de
acordo como o que vemos hoje são os
novos municípios
ou seja esta ideia de que o tecido
urbano e e as suas diferentes
componentes se espalham por territórios
imensos no norte de portugal nós podemos
praticamente da aveiro até muita sorte
de braga sempre navegando em ovos
mexidos sem nunca percebemos onde
comércio nakagawa o que um celular comum
erro em um alentejo e aquilo que faz com
que este conjunto muito fraturado
funciona é aquele sistema de relações
que está ali representado pode ser um
sistema físico como é uma rede elétrica
uma rede de estradas pode ser um sistema
wi fi pode ser um sistema de
distribuição da água de energia e
saneamento ou seja são todos aqui o
sistema social técnicos que fazem com
que alguns um hospital uma casa
comercial fábrica funciona é um mapa
muito detalhado que foi feito para uma
exposição em 2004 em barcelona que vos
dá uma idéia o preto até 75 o vermelho
de 75 até 2004 que vos dá uma idéia do
que é a organização numa área é um
bocado norte em casa sobre o porto e se
tivéssemos mais de graham é mesmo assim
não é o crescimento é mãe chegou e como
vêm os momentos vermelhos aparecem em
todo o lado e no fim de contas não mudam
a estrutura de nuvem que já existia
antes nós só conseguimos olhar para os
pretos e depois as imagens que nós temos
muita gente via aérea ou do google
envolvem nos 10 toda esta diversidade
como se para os biólogos isto é é
bastante familiar como seu território
fosse transgênico
isto é como se eu pudesse ter ao mesmo
tempo elementos que antes dizia que eram
do campo e da floresta eram da fábrica
ou eram da cidade
basta saber que estas coisas hoje em dia
espalham-se desta maneira
atualmente quando só quando olhamos pra
isso pensamos que a proporção de vovô
bené
isso é caótico que isso não funciona já
ouvimos falar da cortiça hoje em dia
isso da cortiça saltarmos projeto os
motores da economia portuguesa eu tenho
uma geografia toda assim é como se
começando em vendas mas acabando em
braga
nós temos uma estrada da empresa e de
emprego a ferramenta que depois ficção
populações e dão lugar a urbanização
fora da cidade
com isso a cidade se tornou uma palavra
quase inútil e ficou encostada terminado
seu terminal dos fenômenos que não estão
mais ou menos familiares como os centros
históricos bom num contexto hoje não
haveria muito tempo para falar isto num
contexto em que a intensificação técnica
é cada vez maior como se vivia naquela
fotografia e isso obviamente que nos
deve fazer pensar
os nossos antepassados da pedra que
dominavam o fogo e pouco mais hoje em
dia estariam ficaram admirados por que
tem imensos imensa as próprias
tecnológicas algumas muito grande como
um avião ou a internet e outras muito
pequenas como um país laico por exemplo
e essa intensidade tecnológica é tal que
obviamente ela influencia no modo como a
sociedade se organiza e portanto no modo
como a sociedade organiza o território e
isso podemos chamar organização
lá vem outra versão tinha outras vezes
pensamos que este é muito difícil pensar
em que palavra cidadãos muito jeito
então encontramos em um só ganso eu só
trouxe dores mais vulgares as cidades
inteligentes vejam que o próprio
grafismos normalmente usado é pra isto
não faz justiça às imagens que mostrei
antes normalmente mostra arranha-céus
setor blocos de apartamentos e
escritórios num mostra casa muito menos
vai rolar até ou então esta ilusão do
azulejo que se ouviu muito falar com
medo enfim que a terra é que essa que os
animais têm os estados
esta ideia de germinar os benefícios
todos alta mas é verdade é que queremos
por fim o grande desafio da urbanidade
hoje em dia ea pobreza
quando é a onu diz a 6 1 70
que finalmente está da população vivia
nas cidades estava nos que estava a
querer dizer que é que aqui a
organização é uma punição da pobreza que
no brasil se chamará favela que se chama
musseque hum hum bico em angola que se
chama sua na índia e esse é que é essa
aqui é verdadeira expressão da
urbanidade
há muita coisa escrita sobre isso sejam
livros técnico esteja literatura mas o
final não só não pára como parece quase
descontrolado se imaginarmos por exemplo
que são paulo pode contar com cerca de
20 milhões de habitantes viver nessas
condições e portanto entre a autora já
escala do próprio fenômeno que se torna
muito muito problemática é um mundo
urbano cada vez mais correspondente a
idéia do território arquipélago ou seja
isso pobres de ricos coisas que não se
relacionam com muita facilidade da e que
cada vez nos tiram mais a idéia de
unidade que nós 20 nós estávamos
habituados a pensar a cidade e nos
transportam para este mundo
esses fenômenos da sociedade que papel i
am e ele fica a unificação dos
movimentos urbanos é em muitas
sociedades toma esta estas
características e que não tem as cartas
estão quase 3.800 apartamentos cercados
é essa tal de aldeia olímpica no rio de
janeiro hoje transformada num condomínio
de luxo foi muito bom para não ficarmos
tristes eu ficaria com uma uti estão ali
ao fundo que diz que dizem mundo das
conexões
isso é que a urbana é o mundo das
aquilo que nós temos o grande desafio
para um pronto a humanidade é conectar a
esta é a assimetria e esta imensa
injustiça que hoje existe no fenômeno da
organização e que está a ser muito
estimulada pela própria globalização da
economia porque a economia liberal não
conhece as regras e planta popular vai
buscar mão de obra quase escrava ele vai
ficar preso fiscal
lá vai vender
não há uma forma de regulamentar e e
voltar a ter nas muralhas imaginárias
estas sociedades territórios que nós
antes chamávamos cidade pobre
[Aplausos]
[Música]